[LAUGH] Okay, let's pick one
more Boolean function to do.
What function am I thinking of?
>> XOR is always good.
>> Let's do XOR.
So what does XOR mean?
Remind me.
>> Okay.
XOR is exclusive or,
which means it's true if A is true or
B is true, but not if they're both true,
so it has elements of both or
and and in it.
>> Right.
>> And I think of XOR usually when I'm,
when I'm, like,
playing with light switches in my house.
If I have a, a light that's activated
by two different light switches,
it's usually an XOR function.
If one is up, the light's on,
if the other one's up,
the lights on, but if they're both up,
the light goes back off.
>> Right.
The other thing when I think of XOR is
when people say or most of the time when
people say or, when they're talking,
they mean xor.
>> Really?
>> Yeah.
So a lot of times when people say or
in English, they really mean xor.
They say, well do you want to go to the
movies or do you want to go swimming?
Do want to eat chicken or
do you want to eat fish?
And really, they're saying either or.
>> I see, you want one or
the other, but you can't have chicken
and fish or go swimming and the movies.
>> No, those things are not
possible to do together.
>> Got it.
Okay.
>> All right, so how would you do XOR?
We got, we still have our-
>> Well, I would start with the-
>> Or, because it's a lot like or.
>> So, what would you want to do?
>> Okay, so to do XOR,
we can split on A.
>> Okay.
>> And there's a true branch and
a false branch.
And what happened with and
and or at this point is,
there is at least one branch where
we actually knew the answer,
at this point, but
I don't think that's true here.
>> That's right.
>> So, so if A is true,
the output might be true or false.
It depends on B.
And if A is false,
the output might be False or True.
It depends on B.
So I-
>> This is exactly right.
So I guess in both cases we
still have to split on B.
>> Okay.
All right.
So, now it should be relatively easy in
the sense that there's a separate
leaf for all possible inputs.
And so we can just write
the XOR function on the bottom.
So if A and B are both true, then the
output is false because it's exclusive.
If A is true and B is false, then it
should be true, because A is true.
If A is false and B is true, then it
should be true because B is true.
And if A and B are both false
then it should be false.
>> That's right.
And by the way,
if you were to think about it for
a little while, it would probably
occur to you that's this tree is
just a another representation
of the full truth table.
>> Very nice.
>> And in fact, if we wanted to do or
again, we could say,
well I was very smart last time, but
I could actually write or like this.
And then just fill out
the values at the bottom.
If A is true and B is true, then yes.
If A is true and B is false, then yes.
If A is false and B is true, then yes.
If A is false and B is false, then no.
And this is a perfectly legitimate a
decision tree to represent or because it
basically is just another simple
representation of the truth table,
but as we pointed out
when did last time,
it's more of a decision
tree than we actually need.
>> I can see that.
>> Because in particular,
we don't actually need this.
All right.
So this little difference here between
writing out the entire truth table on
the left, as we did for XOR, and not
having to write out the entire decision
tree on the right for o,r actually isn't
going to turn out to matter when we
try to do things either more complicated
or with more attributes that we did for
the simple and, or, and XOR.
Would you like to see?
>> Yeah, that sounds really cool.
>> Beautiful.